Hello everyone,
welcome to the Lange Focus Channel and
my name is Paul.
Today we're going to talk about a
language that partially descended from
English but is not actually English.
The language is took piece in an English
based Creole language talk.
BCM is one of the official languages of
Papa New Guinea,
which is located in the southwestern
Pacific Ocean,
just north of Australia.
It's other official languages are
English,
which is not spoken by most of the
population and hedy Motu,
but talk piecing serves as the most
common Lingua Franca.
Lingua Franca is certainly useful in
Papa New Guinea since it's the most
linguistically diverse country on the
planet.
Okay.
It's the most linguistically diverse
country in the whole universe.
Over 800 languages are spoken in Papa
New Guinea,
a country of just around 8 million
people with so much linguistic
diversity.
Talk piecing is frequently used for
communication between people of
different linguistic backgrounds.
Look at the name of the language.
Talk pc talk means language,
but it comes from the English word talk
and also means talk,
speech,
word,
message,
news,
etc.
The majority of top piss in words come
from english,
but are used with different meanings or
with a wider range of meanings.
This word piecing comes from pigeon,
but probably developed from the english
word business,
not in [inaudible],
but rather in the chinese language talk.
Pc has also sometimes been called talk
boy,
boy comes from boy,
but actually refers to someone who was
an indentured laborer,
servant or slave of colonial europeans
because their bosses or masters referred
to them as boy talk,
pissing began as a pigeon language on
the plantations of german Samoa.
Between 1880 and 1914 when laborers from
new Guinea were brought over an english
based creole in a german territory.
Why?
Well laborers from the Solomon Islands
and from Vanuatu had already been
working on plantations in the queensland
colony in present day Australia,
and they had already developed an
english based pigeon language.
In short,
they needed a common language for work,
so they adopted a small english
vocabulary and use the grammar of their
melanesian languages to connect the
words together.
In this way,
a melanesian english based creole
language overall is in queensland.
Some of these pigeons,
speakers from Vanuatu,
Solomon Islands later worked in german
Samoa alongside the new Guinea and
laborers using their pigeon as a lingua
franca.
People from all of these places brought
the pigeon language home with them where
it became widely used as a lingua franca
and became crystallized,
meaning that it became spoken as a
native language for some people and
became used for all functions of life,
not only for the limited functions of
the original pigeon language.
Till this day,
the forms of pigeon spoken in papa new
Guinea and the Solomon Islands and
Vanuatu are all quite though.
They have definitely diverged into their
own distinct varieties.
After pigeon languages become creole
languages,
there are technically no longer pidgin
but they are still referred to as pigeon
in all three countries.
Now let's examine talk pcn and see what
it's like.
Vocabulary as an english based creole
language talk,
pcn got most of its vocabulary from
english,
but words of english origin are usually
pronounced differently according to the
phonological rules of the austronesian
languages of melanesia.
For example,
brother is pronounced enough in before
shark suck.
Stand or stand up,
sun up words of english origin are also
generally used differently than they are
in english.
For example,
class from the english word place in tok
pc in this means village or hometown
area or region from the english word,
devil means soul shadow,
reflection or image plus two from
english,
close to means close to but also nearly
or almost place months from english.
Christmas means birthday and not just to
christ's birthday.
Anyone's birthday.
Since the vocabulary of talked pcn stems
from a small english vocabulary.
Oftentimes one word is used to represent
a wide range of synonyms in english or a
category of words,
for example,
gut from english got or have got this
means to have or to possess.
in top pc,
there's just this one word from english
clothes.
This means clothes but also blouse or
dress us.
This means angry or annoyed or cross in
english.
Cross means mildly annoyed and many
north americans might be unfamiliar with
that word,
but in top pc,
it's the common word for all dEgrees of
anger or annoyance.
Two months from english,
too much.
This means very or very much or greatly
or too much,
and some words have expanded beyond
synonyms to cover a wider range of
meanings.
Stump from english stop.
This means to be located somewhere,
to remain,
to stay,
to rest or to be in progress with this
word.
It might be a bit harder to wrap your
head around.
It's different meanings.
If you stop somewhere than you are there
at that place,
you are remaining there.
You are staying there.
You are situated there.
The meaning of to be in progress stems
from the meaning of remaining because
the action is remaining in progress.
For example,
penn belong me.
Stop long one.
This means where is my pen?
Pen of me is located at what place?
Novel talk pc in vocabulary.
It comes from english.
Some words come from german.
Since Samoa was under german control and
parts of new Guinea.
We're under german control.
When new gideons returned,
well see,
this means to remove or to get rid of.
This comes from german warehouse,
meaning out.
Cool.
meet.
This means rubber and comes from the
german word,
gloomy,
musky.
This means it doesn't matter.
It comes from the german mcneese,
which means the same thing.
Some vocabulary comes from malaya
because of contact with bahasa,
Indonesia on the island of new Guinea
and contact with regional melia
languages,
so soup meaning milk.
This comes from the malaysian word susu.
Some words also come from portuguese
because of early portuguese contact with
melanesia as early as the 16th century,
for example.
This means to know,
to understand,
to know how to,
to be able to,
to be cognizant with or to be accustomed
to.
This comes from portuguese,
so bad,
which means to know vicky,
which means child or baby comes from
portuguese pecking,
you know,
which means little,
and there are also words for many
austronesian languages.
Grammar.
While The vocabulary of top pc in mainly
comes from english,
the grammar largely reflects the
austronesian languages spoken by early
pigeon speakers on the plantations.
Let's look at a few examples here and
later we'll see more grammatical
features in context.
The predicate marker.
All third person sentences contained a
predicate marker.
He
plus
the village doesn't have any water word
for word.
This sentence is village predicate
marker.
No have water.
The word he tells us that what comes
next is the predicate,
the part of the sentence telling us
something about the subject and normally
contains a verb in the language with a
simple vocabulary and grammar.
it would be easy to hear the predicate
as part of the subject if there were no
predicate marker place.
Noga water could be understood as the
village that doesn't have any water,
which would leave the listener waiting
for a predicate to follow because that
whole phrase sounds like the subject.
Next,
the transitive verb marker.
Iem when verbs are transitive,
in other words,
when they are followed by an object,
the suffix him is attached
me like in two months.
This means I really liked beer.
I like really beer.
Liking consists of like from english,
like with the transitive suffix,
him.
This means yesterday.
I saw you on the street yesterday.
I see you on street looking consists of
look from english,
look with the transitive suffix.
Him.
The sentence also contains an
interesting word long,
which brings me to the next point.
Prepositions talk.
Pissing basically has two main
prepositions.
One of them is long,
which comes from english along.
It's used to cover a wide range of
english prepositions in by on with from
to and have a look at this Example
all long monday,
lonely.
This means they went by road on monday
to lay they preposition marker go by
road on monday to lay.
That's the name of a city.
The word old comes from english all but
one of its uses is the third person
plural pronoun.
The other main preposition is belong,
which comes from english,
belong.
It covers the meanings of and for and is
often used to indicate possession.
For example,
this fella emmy,
this is my brother's car,
this predicate marker car of brother of
me.
Next,
the adjective marker paler.
The suffix pillar is normally added to
single syllable adjectives when they
appear before nouns,
so a big tree is the law comes from
english big,
and then the adjective suffix is
attached to it.
[inaudible] is a word from one of
[inaudible] austronesian,
substratum languages.
It's also worth pointing out that this
phrase has no indefinite article talk.
Pc has no definite article and know
indefinite article.
In other words,
no equivalent of the or,
but for Clarity,
one pillar meaning one can be used.
So this phrase could be
one pillar,
one big tree.
Notice that one pillar comes from the
english word,
one with the adjective suffix attached
to it.
Okay.
We've seen some of its key features,
so let's look at a couple more.
Talk pc and samples and break them down.
got enough money long by him.
House can walk him house tussle.
This means if we don't have enough money
to buy a house,
we can just build a house word for word.
It's if we know have enough money to buy
house,
we can build house.
Just suPpose comes from english suppose
and is used to mean if me.
Pella comes from english me,
which on its own would mean I,
but the suffix pillar indicates that
it's the plural form we belong is used
here to mean for by him,
comes from english by and has the
transitive verb.
Suffix,
joachim comes from english work but
means to make build or repair.
Tussle means just or only it comes from
english.
That's all.
And one more example,
and maybe know go through long syncing.
This means he got really drunk at the
party or she got really drunk at the
party he or she predicate marker,
past tense marker,
be drunk,
badly,
really at party m comes from english,
him but is used for both male and female
and for subjects and objects in the sin
been comes from english being and is
used as an aspect marker to show
completion of an action effectively
indicating past tense.
In this sentence,
spock comes from english,
spark and means to be drunk.
No good comes from english,
no good,
true comes from english,
true and is used as an adjective or an
adverb like truly or really long refers
to the location of the action and sing.
Sing is a reduplicate [inaudible] of the
english word sing and is used to mean
sing or song,
but also for a ceremony involving
dancing and singing or for a party.
Let's think about being again for a
minute.
Talk piecing verbs are basically not
conjugated and the verb form is the same
for all persons and numbers and times to
indicate time.
you can use a time word like us day,
meaning yesterday to moda,
etc.
Or you can use an auxiliary verb that
shows aspect like being which shows
completion.
Another option is to place penis from
english,
finish after the verb for the future you
can use like which has the sense of is
about to for things a little farther in
the future.
you can use the word bi or buying by.
For example,
by me come back,
I shall return by and buying bite come
from the old fashioned english
expression by and by meaning after a
short time.
These words indicating an actions
relation to time or not normally
necessary.
If the time is clear from the context
and the adverbs of the sentence,
hopefully this video and the language
samples within it have given you an idea
of what the seen is like.
The english roots of much of its
vocabulary are obvious,
but it's also obvious that talk present
is not english.
It's grammar is very different and even
the vocabulary is generally used quite
differently.
Talk be seen as a language in its own
right.
It's used in the parliament of papa new
Guinea,
it's used in tv and radio broadcasts and
it's used by people all over the country
every day as a lingua franca.
there are books written and talk,
but it's still not widely used as a
literary language,
but there are people who think it can
and should fulfill that function as
well,
but with english also being an official
language and the language of schooling,
some field that english should retain
this role as the formal and literary
language.
The question of the day to native
speakers have talked piece in.
For some people it's hard to imagine how
talk pcns vocabulary is sufficient for
all parts of life.
Do you find that talk?
Pacino is sufficient to say everything
you want to say.
Are there times when it's not and for
other peoplE,
if you want to hear some more talk pc
in,
I will put a link to a top pc in news
broadcast in the description below.
Listen to that clip and let us know in
the comments what you think.
Can you understand any of it?
Does it sound like english?
Be sure to follow lane,
focus on facebook,
twitter,
and instagram,
and once again,
thank you to all of my patrion
supporters,
especially these amazing ones right here
on the screen.
They are my top tier of patrion
supporters.
So many,
many thanks to them and to everyone.
Thank you for watching and have a nice
day.